hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint moins vite
sur messenger
[Musique]
on va démarrer tranquillement
jean-pierre avec celle là vaut rester
d'auto à et quelqu'un va vous appeler un
bien sûr vous lui demandez un vous le
branchez sur des produits il se
retournera garage et de la mer jean
pierre moppert lieu d' y en a il y en a
deux trois venez venez pas venez par la
gentille attention vous allez vous
retournez à tous ceux déguisés vous
appelé empire qui commence qui commence
j'ai tiré mon rôle ici jean-pierre h et
de la mer à tokyo tommy john key et
trèbes admettez-vous dos à là je la sens
très très bien parce que sur celle là on
est sûr ça là on a été sympa à regarder
la ces courts devant et longs derrière
et nora vous l'appelez il aura vous
appeler jean pierre salers et comment
les fast-foods attentes affichées de la
mer
hahaha
[Applaudissements]
mais bien sûr l'afro l'affront voilà m
je peux faire ça pendant deux heures je
ne sais pas c'est vous ah si vous êtes
des avec nous mais il faut lui mettre
des perruques pendant deux heures
attention qu'il appelle jean luc à lys
jean luc jean piat quoi dans la pâte à
tartiner à ces deux là mais ça me va
bien
ça vous va bien jean-pierre allez on va
alors celle-là ça la jda son grade je
pense que ça va être la dernière
c'est l'âge au lasso grave isabelle vous
l'appelez vous avez prévu quelque chose
un texte
ouais qu'est ce que vous pensez des
oeufs en tube homicide la mer
donc on peut faire ça la clé la dernière
avant après après j'arrête de vous
embêter salage de la saga avant
d'ajouter on a beau chine déjà l'affront
a été vénéré jo attention aux lacets
l'accusation bien aux gens lui canisy
jean-pierre qu'est ce que vous pensez du
jambon des charcuteries mon petit gars
j'ai pas de la mer